hey guys I'm Stephanie I am a former
preschool teacher and we're gonna talk
horror stories being a preschool teacher
was pretty rough a lot of people think
gosh it's just kids and it's cute
there's a lot of bodily fluids there's a
lot of screaming there's a lot of crying
high school can be a dream come true
it can also be somewhat of a nightmare
you never know what problems are gonna
come up and it's usually what you don't
think is going to be the worst case
scenario that ends up being the worst
case scenario sometimes preschools have
to use programs which means they're not
potty trained which means they wear
diapers which you would think could
prevent any kind of bathroom
catastrophes that is an incorrect
assumption because let me tell you that
will go everywhere ha ha ha
including on you we're in the middle of
like cold and flu season
I had sick kids in class before kids
when their snotting there they're not
like aware that they're starting you
know so they just kind of go up to you
and they're like oh so I am always like
in your elbow like wipe your nose blow
your nose and I once had a girl who was
kind of snotting and I kind of bent down
to her level cuz I she was like I need a
tissue so I got me tissue and I bent
down it secured to you and I was right
in her face speaking to her when she
sneezed in my mouth this one I was naive
no one had ever sneezed in my mouth and
I couldn't like come like yell at her
like it's a sneeze you know like just it
took a minute to panic and think about
like all the different bacteria that are
now introduced to my system and god I
don't remember what I did I probably
just a mystery and for days I was a
student teacher working in my Center we
had gone through the day pretty normally
like it was a pretty normal day and then
lunch time came around and I'm walking
around cleaning up after my lead
teachers and such and all of a sudden
one of them pukes and we're just like oh
okay
cuz you know puke happens it happens you
know so we get that child cleaned up
sent home eventually we think it's over
later in the day I was cleaning our toy
sanitizing our toys and then all of a
sudden another kid peers like oh no oh
gosh
so my lead teacher grabs her and holds
her over a trash can so cuz she just
keeps keeps vomiting keeps vomiting he's
coming up and I'm like okay and then
another kid starts puking while this one
is puking and we're like oh god oh god
so we're like trying to get them cleaned
up trying to get them over the trashcan
before they get on everything because
then I have to sanitize it it's the end
of the day so their parents are coming
any minute and so we're trying to get
all this situated so finally they go
home me and my leader like oh my god
that was not we think it's over now you
think I am old and wise but no I didn't
learn so I also then had you know I'm
always very sympathetic when a kid was
feeling sick and you know he was like
time he was feeling sick I was look a
little out of it so I bent down I'm
short but you always like bend down to
the level of the child to really get
them to talk to you and he wasn't really
talking I was like what's going on I
thought I was being bullied a sec come
on and so I got really really close to
his face and then he just looked up and
projectile vomited all over me like from
this distance it was maybe four states
of my life so finally they go home me
and my leader like oh my god that was
not we think it's over about a week and
a half later it is not over we have a
staff meeting we're all sitting we have
lots of pizza it's a lot of fun we're
learning things I'm walking back to my
dorm and I'm just kind of like wow I
hate a lot of pizza my stomach just
feels so full and like as I'm sitting in
my dorm this pizza just feels like it is
not digesting it's just sitting next
thing I know I'm like blanching my face
is just like and I'm like oh god I'm
gonna puke is the dorm so we have
communal bathrooms so I have to run down
the hall run at all puke is getting
everywhere and I'm just like oh my god
oh my god I'm dying and I
like in the shower because a maintenance
guy comes in he's like are you okay and
I'm like not really but I'll get there
and so then I'm like I have a fever I'm
like shaking I get back to my dorm and
I'm like and I google it and whatever
those kids had had an incubation period
of about a week and I was like ah so
it's just now hitting me so I call out
of work only to find out that a few
other teachers had also called out and
we were all puking Pizza everywhere that
was the story of the puke pocalypse of
my two-year old classroom for a few
weeks I was teaching one of my students
just to kind of we were tossing a ball
back and forth and I was showing them
how to you know lift it up in the air
and catch it super simple stuff one day
we took a field trip a little minor hike
out into the woods and I watched as the
same boy who'd been practicing throwing
a ball up in the air throw a rock up in
the air and he watched it as it came all
the way down and split open his forehead
and blood gushed everywhere he was
screaming other kids were screaming
other kids well we're also worried that
the blood was going to get on them it
definitely felt guilty for not teaching
him how to catch the ball better and
saying like keep an eye on it
he took it all the way so truly it's
it's my fault
and I take full responsibility for it I
was subbing I had a location I had never
been to and normally if you're the sub
in a class it's like guarantee that
you're just gonna be on back from duty
the entire time life continues to get
worse with and I discovered that I was
assigned the only kid in the classroom
that wasn't potty-trained and wasn't
wearing a diaper
hashtag why it was one of these parents
that were adamant that their kid was
potty-trained
you know insisted that like he had to
learn the hard way when all that really
happened was I had to learn the hard way
that wearing a onesie and having a
number two disaster a bad day mix we
rushed him down the mountain we got him
to first
we checked in with our primary like
nurse they're like I don't think you
need stitches but definitely need to
call the parents parents came and I was
really apologetic because I do feel like
it was on my watch and it was through
whatever training I'd given him are not
giving him but I was shocked that the
parent was pretty nonchalant about it
like stuff like this had apparently
happened quite a bit to this student he
was very accident-prone and the fact
that the parents didn't have to take the
student to a nurse or a doctor or a
hospital and get stitched up
honestly it liked it ranked low for them
so for me I'm freaking out I don't know
what to do they're like yeah we just
call this Tuesday in our household which
okay great and I really hope wherever
you are you are a live kid I really do
once upon time it was a Tuesday got to
work and a kid had brought in a book
that was about I don't know some forest
creature you know how it goes anyway at
one point
Bambi style is the book the forest cute
little creatures mother died to which my
students responded what happened where
the mom go to which I said dear God
kill me now then I too will be dead and
have to avoid this question it's pretty
pretty rough when you reach a moment in
child's life where you may or may not be
the person to break to them that living
comes to an end I wasn't really prepared
that day for like an existential crisis
moment I basically I sat down and look
those toddlers in their bright innocent
eyes and I was like well you know
sometimes in nature in the wild animals
exist and then sometimes in the circle
of life you know lion king and they're
like yeah you know in the circle of life
things happen it's all it's all just a
process it's all a cycle and then
luckily they're just you know they're
short attention spans kick into gear and
then they want to play with blocks and
they've forgotten the
asked an incredibly unnerving question
two minutes prior all right guys I don't
know what's tell you a blood sweat tears
ABC all of it coming together preschool
can be absolutely crazy so be nice to
all the preschool teachers out there
they're doing the best they can to raise
you
now we don't we know that we just need
to wash our hands and sanitize as often
as possible be nice to teachers
especially of young children because
they've probably been thrown up on more
than once because I know I'm not the
only one it's a roller coaster you
really have to be ready for anything to
happen at any time of the day so that I
survived yeah so you know when you get
hit with those hard eating questions
that toddlers will volley into your
court just avoid them at all costs
that's what I would say if you ever have
a diaper catastrophe just buckle up get
some wipes and count your blessings it's
gonna be a rocky ride
[Music]